let's get started talking about the big
news out of ottawa what's happening with
this with this crackdown daily mail
reports trudeau's trucker crackdown
begins hundreds of cops backed by
armored vehicles and horses
arrest at least 100 freedom convoy
protesters in ottawa and tow 21 big rigs
using emergencies act power so
we got a bunch of photos out of here
mounted officers showing up people
screaming you've got plane you've got
regular you know
looks i don't know if these are like
community officers or what they're not
wearing armor or anything like that but
here you've got what appeared to be some
kind of riot control armed with tear gas
gas masks look at this guy look i've
seen this stuff throughout my time i've
seen it at violent riots i've seen it at
well mostly violent riots typically when
i see peaceful protesters you might see
stuff like this but you don't see this
the severity i've certainly seen police
brutality at peaceful protests
especially from the left don't get me
wrong but this seems to be absolutely
overplayed and extreme for a bunch of
you know middle-aged truckers and
families with their kids and dogs and
about and a bouncy castle i understand
people are like well sometimes there's
there's confrontations yeah come on it's
a peaceful occupation in a city they
should be coming in with like 10
officers peacefully taking saying look
guys you know you broke the law we're
going to take you in slap on the wrist
instead it is trudeau fascism crackdown
freezing people's assets trampling
people with horses dark days indeed huh
is this the group that had the bouncy
house outside the yes uh very scary
nothing scarier than a bunch of
middle-aged truckers with a bouncy house
for their kids uh that is what i would
live in fear of what you think you think
you're joking but no seriously they
don't know how to respond to it when
when you get a violent riot the state
says oh thank heavens because they know
that they're going to earn public
support for shutting down riots even
when they barely do it but when you got
little kids in a bouncy house they're
like
whatever we do it's gonna look really
really bad how do we handle this they do
get scared of that stuff i suppose it's
kind of like in the past when they would
have kids at the front lines of the
protests or the riots right to
to prevent police action right it's the
left does it all the time it's an optics
thing yep
yeah they're even threatening to go
after journalists this is like uh uh um
how a monarchy doesn't know how to
respond to a peaceful protest they talk
about canada's all about i'm not saying
canada is the monarchy but the queen
could stop this if she wanted
they talk about like peace we need
calmness and peace you guys and then
when stuff like this breaks out they
don't know what to do because it's this
fake
you know this platitude of kindness and
peace you guys know this is fascist
militant you know quasi democracy so now
we're seeing the true colors of how in
america we fight each other for fun
that's wha and so we don't get to this
point because we know how to deal with
protest it's like this country is a
protest it's something you told me it's
a great way to look at uh our species
the way it functions the way the
importance of resistance
this is bothering me
yeah
dark days indeed
now i wonder what will happen in the u.s
because uh uh you know d.c police are
saying they're gonna uh they're pulling
leave because they're worried about this
as well i can't say i'm surprised about
canada though uh for those that didn't
get the episode yesterday we had a
canadian guy stephen marchand he wrote a
book about civil war
and i think his perspective is really
interesting i think i disagree with him
to a great deal but he was basically
saying in the united states there's two
countries a multicultural democracy and
a constitutional republic and i was like
wow that's that's a that's an excellent
way to point out what's happening and of
course the united states isn't always
has been a constitutional republic
therefore the multicultural democracy he
speaks of is supplanting our our culture
our country our society and that's very
much what canada is
canada has been for a long time
he mentioned how you know canada is very
unstable and he was surprised the us was
destabilizing and i'm like the us has
been stable because we are a
constitutional republic it's a safeguard
to make sure there's you know from from
the smallest jurisdiction and up people
have representation yeah you know it
doesn't seem like you get that with
canada it seems like they just don't
care about you you're a cog in their
machine
if you watch canadian parliament that
was that was the feeling i got it's it's
like a clown show like it's dude's
wearing a big white puffy outfit you're
like what in the hell and then they
start they heckle each other like how
can you get any it's the weirdest
ancient practice tradition or whatever
the hell but it is not like stable well
i i i was uh doxed this week as a
contributor to the freedom convoy gibson
go uh congratulations yeah i was
actually quite proud of it it was a it
was a positive experience i was so proud
uh but i've i've been team convoy since
day one on this and it means so much to
so many of us i look at australia i look
at canada i look at even italy my
favorite country to visit and i don't
even recognize these places and it makes
me so proud to be an american in a red
state i live in texas work in tennessee
vacation florida my last two years have
been basically okay outside of
all the knowledge but you were you were
in california you were in california for
for 15 years now back then would you
have dared speak up in support of this i
would have but uh i knew the tide was
turning so heavily that in 2014 i left i
took my whole family and went back to
texas oh so you got out early oh i saw
it all coming i couldn't have told you
what was coming but i felt it coming i
know exactly what you're talking about
yeah because i was living in new york
and i kept slowly moving away because it
just seemed to be getting worse and
worse until we end up in west virginia
or you know this whole area yeah yeah
because i don't want to be in a big city
and then you look at what happens with
the lockdowns so we were actually we
moved to this to south jersey and then
when they did the hard lockdown i was
like we got to get out of here like i'm
not going to sit around and wait to find
out how bad it does get and and it got
bad we had we had those risers back in
2020 the riots crossed the bridge from
philly into south jersey and i was like
yo i'm done with that i'm getting out
we're going to the middle of nowhere
we're going to do our own thing we're
going to build their own space not to
mention i'll be completely honest way
cheaper out here for land so expanding
the business there's way more
opportunity but i think there's a huge
opportunity in pushing back from a lot
of the stuff by rejecting it when when
we see this going down in canada my i
have one thing to say to all of this
confidence and the system is being
broken
if if you can't even uh i'm look i can't
speak for canada i don't know what
canada does but uh for us down here we
see what's happening with the vaccine
mandates they're kind of being shattered
or you know how bad it's been
talk about multiple multicultural
democracy or whatever but when you
cannot get a redress of grievances
you're looking at a hard fall for for
your society when you look at the
dysfunction in congress when you look at
the fact that it's being run by people
like nancy pelosi i'm just like that is
shattering i'm gonna i'm gonna go and
start setting up something somewhere
else to get away from this because to
put it simply confidence in the system
be it canada be it the uk be it the eu
beat the united states
it's fracturing and so it's time to make
sure that you're shoring up our defenses
we're building something substantive on
a run that we control that's that's
going to be
isolated from this otherwise it shatters
along with it
i hope that the freedom convoy thing if
nothing else i really hope that it
shatters people's normalcy bias this
understanding this thinking that it
can't happen here because trust me i i
never thought i would see something like
this in canada canada is the nicest
place in the world they never do
anything crazy or edgy this is wild to
me what like literally watching them
tonight the videos going around twitter
of the mounted police
um just literally walking over people
i want to give a good shout out to
my conservative friends
who
uh uh specifically not all i'm not
saying all conservatives the ones who
defended ron desantis and florida
passing the the anti-riot uh bill that
would make it a felony to block roads
i said now you don't want to do that
because we want to tolerate some degree
of unrest because now we see what
happens in canada and we're going to be
seeing what happens with the dc protest
with this with this convoy i think we
should respect people who want to
peacefully obstruct it's annoying but we
tolerate a certain give to the system
you need that flexibility otherwise if
it's too brittle it shatters but i also
want to shout out a lot of these
conservatives um ezra levant i think it
was had a great tweet where he said he
used to be back the blue he would always
give the cops the benefit of the doubt
now he's seeing what they're doing to
trampling old women and in front of
children and i'm like
i got to tell you man
there are a lot of moderate there are
amount of there are a lot of liberals
who have been saying exactly this for
some time
now i get it when you get black lives
matter and often lying lying in it to
incite violence the michael brown stuff
was a lie the trayvon martin stuff was a
lie ahmed arbory stuff was a lie george
floyd stuff was a lie i get it you're
like i'm not going to believe these
people and i totally agree i'm not going
to believe them either but i'll tell you
this when i was in ferguson
i saw
police
just lob a flashbang into a crowd of
people unprovoked i've seen and there's
videos of things like this this stuff
happens so there's a certain degree that
i'm willing to tolerate because i think
policing is an important institution but
you get to the point where they're not
stopping the rights in these big cities
the big cities vote for this they they
they're the ones rioting they're the
ones supporting these mayors and these
democrats and these appointees they're
the ones cheering on the police
defending the illegal seizure funds to
paint political message in the street
and i'm just like
why would i defend any of these cops
from the writers when they're a part of
that same system then you see other cops
come in and shut down small businesses
over covered lockdown and i'm just like
okay that's it i'm out look duly elected
law enforcement seems to do a really
great job sheriff's you know i we have a
great relationship with our cops out
here but these big city cops are
basically part of that multicultural
democracy establishment democrat machine
they can they can live however they want
to live i'm not going to i'm not going
to intervene when they try to defund
those departments or now in austin where
they're arrested they're indicting 19
officers an aggravated assault i'm like
you know what i don't want to live in
austin you all voted for that
congratulations officers you get it
i understand the isolation mentality and
i was thinking about this a lot too
because if if we really hit like a bad
place of civil war or like where all the
power went out you'd get roving bands of
militants that are like really good at
what they do it's called uh
uh i don't know what you call it but not
imbalanced war what do they call it
where like one side is way better than
the other side asymmetrical asymmetrical
war you'll get people they'll go from
house to house and raid every other like
12 guys with machine guns or or
semi-autos raiding house by house to get
all the valuables and like everyone
these americans are like i got my guns
i'm safe i'm going to stay here in my
house but you're a sitting target these
people know how to conquer and control
and there will be so i understand the
desire to isolate but those kind of
things will come for you if you try and
isolate you have it is good to be out in
in the country and have space but
isolation is not the answer you need to
be involved consciously with your fellow
man that's where we do movies and tv and
music and internet video and things like
that you're you're right i agree
what i would uh say
i don't think the goal should be to try
and infiltrate their systems
you know for a long time um moderates
left libertarian like left left liberal
libertarian types have been complaining
about movies and video games getting
woke and doing all this other stuff
because they genuinely believed they
were in the same system with these
people
when i say to you i don't like your
video game because you did these things
is because i believe genuinely we're
working together as one society on a
product
i think people need to realize they're
not treating you that way and they don't
care what you think and they're gonna do
whatever they want in which case
you don't wanna isolate yourself you
wanna make something better on your own
and attract the people who are
disillusioned by them to come and join
you
as one civilization as one society
that's exactly right and i and i spent
enough time in hollywood to understand
that and that's something i feel very
passionately about a year ago when i
went on ben's sunday special i talked
about parallel economies
and this is so important to me because a
parallel hollywood
is in my opinion the only answer right
there are not uh
ways for me to get the movies that i
want to make politics aside in
traditional hollywood right now they're
not supported in fact they're
discouraged or even disallowed and so i
had to
go and try to create a parallel economy
where i wasn't going to get attacked i
wasn't going to get uh you know i wasn't
going to be tolerated i was going to be
celebrated and you know we're just
getting started but it's game on right
now thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you